déjà un homme qui avait la santé et du
travail
c'était beau s'il ne buvait pas
demander mieux bon ben il cherchait à
la chaude bon ben je voulais pas parce
qu'il avait bu ou alors il me frappait
vous voyez c'était déjà un motif mais il
fallait subir sinon c'était toute la
nuit qui faisait des comédies des
serenades alors pour que les enfants
puissent être tranquille et pourquoi
être tranquille mais Facebook c'était le
maître moi on me disait mon mari me
disait enfin mais Marie me disait toi de
toute façon tu n'es qu'une femme
tais-toi tu ne sais pas vous pouviez pas
vous permettre de tenir tête à vos maris
c'était des discussions
madame alors ma mère parce qu'elle était
très malheureuse elle avec mon père
alors elle me disait écoute Fernande
fais comme moi soit souple mais je dis
oui mais des fois un moment tu sais mais
dis ça se passera tu verras tu verras
que ça se passeraille et en effet je
l'ai écouté puis ça se passait